이걸 안 하는 거는 정말 리스크 한
거 이거 안 하시는 분들도 많더라고요
이걸 안 하는 거는 유명한 맛집 가서
번호표를 안 뽑고 기다리고 있는
거예요 그냥
[음악]
최근에 뉴스 기사만 보면
빌라 왕 전세 사기 관련돼서 기사가
매일 나오는 거 같습니다 오늘은
공인중개사로서 전세의 사기
피해 안 당하는 방법에 대해서
알려드리도록 하겠습니다
[음악]
계약 전에
등기사항 정부 증명서 이건 인터넷에
누구나 다 열람이 가능하고
700원만 내면 출력할 수 있습니다
보통은 다 이제 계약 당일날 보는
경우가 많은데 최소 하루 전에는
출력을 해서
갚고 갑구는 그 소유권에 관한 사항이
나오니까 소유자가 누군지 그리고
울구는 소유권 이외 그러니까 이제 뭐
근저당권이라든지 대출 얼마나 받았는지
그런게 이제 일구에 나옵니다 그래서
소유자가 누군지 반드시 확인하셔야
되고 여러분들의 전세금을 반드시
소유자한테 이치를 하셔야 돼요 전세
사기 유형 중에 하나가 뭐 중개사한테
준다든지 아니면 대리인한테 준다든지
뭐 이런 경우가 있는데 그게 아니라
무조건 갑부의 소유자한테 지급을
하셔야 됩니다 전세금이 말소된
내역들도 한번 봐 보세요이 내역을
보니까
임차권 설정 등기가
됐다가 이렇게 말소되어 있는 이력이
있다라고 하면은 뭘 유추해 볼 수
있냐면 아이 사람이
지금은 한번 안 돌려준 적이 늦게
돌려준 적이 있구나 뭐 이런게 좀
유추가 가능하거든요 지금 등기사항
정문 증명서 자체가 이런 기록부염과
다 남아이 사람이
어떤 사람인지가 좀 나와 있어요
압류가 됐다가 말소될 수도 있잖아요
세금을 안 난대요들이 있다든지 지금
당장은 설정이 돼 있지는 않지만
그래도 유추는 해볼 수 있습니다
대리인이 올 경우에는
인감증명서와 위임장을 챙겨 와야 되고
위임장에는
민감도장이 찍혀 있어야 됩니다
그래서요 도장이랑
인감증명서 도장이랑 맞는지 확인을
하셔야 됩니다 대리인 신분증은 당연히
필요하고 그리고 더 나아가서는
소유자와 전화를 해보셔야 돼요 전화
내가 지금 이렇게 전세 계약을 하려고
하는데
동의하시는지이 사람한테 대리권을
준게 맞는지 이거를 왜 확인하냐면 또
사기 유형 중에 또 하나가이 중간에
있는 사람이 집주인이랑은
월세 계약을 하는 거예요 그리고요
사람이
다른 사람이랑은 전세계약을
체 있습니다이 사람은 전세금을 먹고
주인한테는
임대료만 내고 그 집주인은 모르고
있는 겁니다 그냥 대리권을 줬으니까
그래서 여러분들이 만약에 대리인이
왔다라고 하면은이 집주인이랑 통화를
반드시 좀 해보셔야 됩니다 만약에
내가 다가구주택을 들어간다라고 하면은
전입세대를 열람할 수 있어요
다가구주택 같은 경우에는 그 한 사람
소유의 주택에
여러 사람이 사는 거예요 그 먼저
들어온 사람이 뭐 확정일자를
대항력이랑 이런게 있으면은 그 사람이
우선해서 좀 봤거든요 그 사람이
번호표를 더 빨리
가지고 있어요 그런 거는이 전입세대
열람을 떼보셔야지 알 수 있습니다 그
다음에 완납 증명서 세금이 만약에
체납되어 있으면은 그게 제일 우선해서
받아요
법안 얘기 중인 거 중에 하나는
전입신고랑 확정일자 받은 뒤에 이제
세금이 체납됐다라고 하면 이제
후순위로 밀려나는 그런 법안이 좀
얘기 중이긴 합니다 그리고
전세보증보험 가입이 가능한지를 체크를
하셔야 돼요 이게 안 될 수도
있거든요 뭐 금액이 안 될 수도 있고
뭐 근저당권 설정 금액이 높아서 안
되는 경우도 있고 여러분들이 미리
가입이 가능한지
체크를 하셔야 돼요 그리고 만약에
만약에 이게 가입이 되지 않으면
계약은 무효로 한다 뭐 이런 특약을
둘 수도 있고요 그리고 이게 만약에
신탁이 되어 있다 뭐 어디 어디 자산
신탁에 등기가 되어 있다라고 하면은
신탁 원부를 떼서 봐야 돼요
신탁등기가 되어 있으면 보통 어디
어디 자산신탁 이렇게 돼 있거든요
그런 경우에는 신탁 원부를 떼서 봐야
됩니다 그래서 신탁원부는 뭐 대출
금액이라든지 실제 소유자가 누군지가
나와 있거든요 그리고 무엇보다 제일
중요한 건
매매 시세 전세 시세까지 같이 확인을
해야 됩니다 뭐 워낙 요즘에 뭐
실거래가 오픈되어 있는 곳이라든지
그런데가 그래도 많기 때문에 한번
관심을 갖고 찾아보시면 좋을 것
같아요 내 전세금액이
매매가의
70%, 70% 넘어간다라고 하면은
이거는 위험 부담이 되게 큰 거예요
전세 계약할 때 되게 좀 많이 유의를
하셔야 됩니다 그걸 알려면 전세
시세랑 매매 시세를 확인하셔야 돼요
보통 이제 언론에 많이 나오는 그
사회초년생 그다음에 신혼부부 분들이
대부분 다이 시세를 확인 못해서요
그리고 오늘 기사 보니까 전세 사기가
제일 많이 일어난 데가
화곡동이라고 하더라고요 거기 있는
가보시면
신축 빌라가 너무 많아요
화곡동 자체가 그 공항 옆에 있어
가지고 건물을 일단은 뭐 높게 못
찍고 재개발 뭐 재건축이 좀 쉽지
않은 동네거든요 그런 것 때문에 그런
업자들이 좀 많이 와요 이쪽으로 거기
워낙 땅이 또 싸거든요 그래서 거기
신축 빌라 가보면 거의 막
풀옵션이에요 너무 상태가 좋은 거예요
서울이랑 되게 근교인데 그래서 많은
이런 사회 초년생이나 이런
신혼부부들이 거기 좀 많이 들어가는데
그 매매 시세보다 아니면 거의 더
근접하게
노래를 들어가는 거예요 그래서 문제가
좀 많이 발생되는 경우가 많거든요
특히 신축 빌라가 되게 심합니다
신축 빌라 자체가 이런 중개하시는
분들한테
피를 많이 줘요 수수료 이상의 비용
그런 것들 때문에 이런 중개업 하시는
분들도 좀 그쪽으로 많이 소개하시는
분들도 있고네 그리고 건축물대장을 또
확인하셔야 돼요 건축물대장은
민원24에서
출력을 할 수 있습니다
요거를 보면은 뭐 불법 증축한 경우도
있고 그 다음에 근생 부분인 경우도
있으니까 근린생활시설 그러니까 이제
근린생활시설로 받고 거기는 이제
원룸으로 방을 쪼개는 경우도 있거든요
그래서 이런 경우에는 보증보험이
가입이 안 됩니다 그래서 이런 것도
좀 확인하셔야 되니까 미리 확인을
해야 돼요 계약전 그리고
계약 후에는
전입신고를 해야 되고
확정일자 점유를 하고 있어야 대항력이
발생되요
그런 경우도 있어요
잔금일 할 대출을 받는 거예요 그러면
그 잔금일 날 받은 은행이 내
보증금보다 더 선순위가 되는 거예요
저는 다음날 생기니까 그래서 그런
내용들을 뭐 잔금일이나 계약
체결일로부터 뭐 권리 변동을 하지
않는다 이런 경우에는 뭐
임대인이 뭐 책임진다는 그런 문구를
좀 넣으셔야 돼요 이게 다음날
발생되니까 그래서 전입신고 확정일자
그 다음에 건물 인도를 받아야
대항력이 발생됩니다 이걸 안 하는
거는 정말
리스크 하는 거 이거 안 하시는
분들도 많더라고요 이걸 안 하는 거는
유명한 맛집 가서 번호표를 안 뽑고
기다리고 있는 거예요
전입신고 확정일자 무조건 받아야
됩니다 여러분들이 또 아셔야 될게
집주인이 보증금을 안 빼줄 때가
있어요 근데 보증금을 안 빼줬는데
이사할 집을 구해 놓은 거예요 미리
그래서 그쪽으로 옮기는 분도 있습니다
집 주소라든지 짐을 다 빼가지고
옮기는 경우가 있는데 그런 경우에는
대항력이 상실되요 그래서 여러분들이
만약 이사할 집이 있다 하더라도
전입이라든지
짐을 다 빼거나 그러면 안 돼요 근데
또 언제까지 안 뺄 순 없잖아요
그래서 또 해야 될게
임차권 등기 명령제도라는게 있어요
그래서 요거는 따로 집주인의 뭐
동의는 필요 없거든요
계약이 끝난 다음에 이제 할 수 있는
거여서 여러분도 알고 계셨다가 그냥
무턱대고 이사할 집에 전입이나 뭐
그렇게
짐 다 옮기시지 말고
임차권 등기 제도라는 걸 조금
이용하셔서 내 보증금은 좀 안전하게
지킬 수 있으면 좋을 것 같습니다
잘
준비하고 대비해서 내 안전한 소중한
전세 보증금을
꼭 지키셨으면 좋겠습니다
[음악]